good afternoon
it being one o'clock I'll call the
fiscal committee to order
and and I would like to uh
announce that the acting clerk will be
representative erf
by law the chairman of house finance is
the chairman of the fiscal committee
and I now will like to nominate a vice
chair and I would like to nominate
Senator Gray
second and I will second that
any fur any further nominations
all in favor Senator Grace say aye aye
any opposed Senator gray congratulations
as I said the committee clerk will be
Senator I will be representative erf and
also every biennium we appoint the
legislative budget assistant
and I appoint Mr Michael Kane as the
legislative budget assistant second
sure thank you you'll just have to take
a motion on the clerk just to a point
representative all right sorry
motion to nominate the clerk second
Motion in a second all in favor say aye
aye opposed no you are elected thank you
okay
all right now
I have nominated uh Michael Kane as the
legislative budget assistant is there a
second second
further further nomination seeing none
all in favor say aye aye any opposed
congratulations thank you very much
go over briefly the fiscal committee
rules and procedures
committee requires that any requested
action made pursuant to RSA 124 colon 15
establishing any new position or
continuation of an existing position
either full-time or part-time or the
hiring of Consultants be for the current
biennium only
rule 2 the committee requires that any
requested action made pursuant to RSA 14
colon 30 Dash lowercase a Romans 6 the
acceptance and expenditure of funds over
one hundred thousand for many non-state
Source before the current biennium Only
Rule three that any requests made to the
committee under the following statutes
either individually or a combination
thereof will be placed on a consent
calendar and voted on as a block
any member May request that item be
removed from the consent calendar for
further discussion and or clarification
prior to or during the fiscal committee
meeting
rsa's 9 colon 16
lowercase a transfers authorized RSA 9
colon 16 lowercase C transfer of Federal
grant funds RSA 9 colon 17--d transfer
Appropriations judicial branch RSA 14
colon 30 a Romans 6 acceptance and
expenditure of funds over one hundred
thousand from any non-state source and
RSA 124 colon 15 positions restricted
acceptance of a late item requires
approval of the chairman
and I authorize the legislative
legislative budget assistant to Grant
step increases for employees of the LBA
office on the employee's anniversary
dates and Etc that times for exceptional
Services determined by the Legislative
budget assistant legislative budget
assistant will inform the fiscal
Committee in writing when these step
increases have been granted
promote any an LBA employee or
reclassify a position with prior
approval of the chairman of the fiscal
committee and to fill a vacancy in the
LBA office with the prior approval of
the full vacancy of the full fiscal
committee
we've had two sets of minutes from
previous meeting
we have a November 18th and December 2nd
I'd like a motion on December 18th move
to approve excuse me uh Mr chair sorry
just my cane here if you could take a
motion on your administrative rules and
procedures I'm sorry all right as as
read the administrative rules and
procedures move to approve move to
approve second second
further discussion seeing none all in
favor say aye
aye opposed no they are adopted thank
you
all right
now we'll move to the minutes from
previous meetings
first for November 18
2023 move to approve motion to approve
is there a second
any further discussion any omissions or
Corrections seeing 90 ready for the vote
all in favor say aye aye aye opposed no
those are adopted next the December 2nd
meeting moved to approve
is there a second
further discussion any omissions are
correction seeing none all in favor say
aye
aye opposed no those are adopted
because of somebody's schedule we're
going to be taking out of order
the uh
KPMG report that's coming later
where they have done the the audits of
the
performance audit the the kafir and the
performance audit of the turnpike yes
good afternoon
if you see the red light we'll know you
talking all right
good afternoon and thank you
and thank you chairman and committee my
name is Marie Zimmerman I am the lead
audit partner from KPMG I have over 22
years of experience on KPMG and I've
previously audited the state from 2014
to
2017. so I'm so proud to be back as your
external auditor with you here today
today is a testament to das and Dana her
Management Group as well as LBA Steve
and his management team who proactively
issued and embraced technology while
ensuring the integrities of the State
financial statements
we thank you both for your coordination
and your cooperation with us throughout
the audit
included in your packet today is our
kpmg's presentation which includes our
required Communications as well as our
um
bindings over finding over the internal
controls on financial reporting
verse going through each page by Page
I'd like to just highlight a few items
to you
we did perform our audit in accordance
with government generally accepted
accounting governmental standards we did
Issue an unmodified or clean opinion
which is the best opinion you can
receive over the financial reporting
these this opinion is multiple opinions
we issued an opinion over the
governmental activities the business
like activities the aggregate discreetly
presented component units each made your
fund and the aggregate remaining funds
those incorporate other Auditors the
largest being the which we refer to was
the pension trust funds
we also issued our required
supplementary our opinion in relation to
for the supplementary schedules that's
over the mdna and the required on
schedules of your opeb and pension plans
that was also a clean opinion as it
related to the financial statements of
the basic the basic financial statements
we concluded they were fairly presented
our other required communication that
you can see in our packet was over
internal controls on financial reporting
we identified two uncorrected audit
misstatement and two corrected
misstatements we received and confirmed
with management that the effects of the
uncorrected financial
uncorrected misstatements did not have a
material account or impact on the
financial statements individually and in
the aggregate
the one corrected misstatement did
result in a material weakness which
you'll see in your packet on slide four
as it related to unemployment Securities
it was a partially due to the advances
of the federal funds that occurred
during the pandemic
we did Issue a yellow book report which
is a report on internal controls over
financial reporting and compliance in
other matters of the audit which will be
filed with the federal government with
your single audit later in the year that
report did also note no significant
deficiencies and the one material
weakness
we had no disagreements with management
throughout the audit and no significant
difficulties during the audit which is
again is a testament to your financial
reporting process and internal controls
I like to open it up to see if anyone
has any questions today for me
any questions for the auditor from from
the members of the fiscal committee
saying none thank you very much thank
you
Mr Smith any comments
no I think at the at the end of the
meeting I believe if Department
administrative Services either
comptroller or the commissioner will
maybe have them then unless
that'll work okay and just to remind the
committee that all the audits today the
reports were accepted and approved for
release when available back in at the
November meeting so that's a task you
don't have to do today so the rest of
the audits will be presented at the end
of the meeting
thank you very much anything further
is there a motion to approve the report
we don't need it it's been done all
right and congratulations
commissioner arlinghaus to your
financial staff
anyone you wish to recognize
particularly for these reports
congratulations to them thank you
all right moving on to our agenda we'll
go to Tab four
recommendation by the Legislative
performance audit oversight committee
that a performance audit be done
on the commission for human rights
a motion to approve so moved
motion second to approve the performance
audit oversight recommendation
further discussion seeing none
representative Birdsall
did and I know I'm not sure whether
every Department because I'm new to this
committee I'm not sure whether every
department is required to get a
performance audit but in speaking with
her they have made some significant
changes in their processes and I I just
don't understand the need for for an
audit so I will be voting against it
thank you
the performance on an oversight
committee meets this looks at various
things that they bring from their
experience they recommend it and give a
little Spiel on why they recommend it
and if they're supported by the rest of
the committee then it comes to us so
performance audits aren't done on every
agency but they're done on a regular
basis and you know we look for where
people think they have a problem and
they bring it forward and try to
convince the rest of the committee and
if that's so then it comes to us for
approval
thank you
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair I I think it may also uh help
Senator Birdsall if I've if I've heard
this right at this point in the process
it would take a unanimous vote of the
fiscal committee to not do this audit
that the the audit at this point is
pretty much guaranteed unless all of us
said no is that the case sir
yes thank you
yeah
Senator Dallas thank you Mr chairman uh
I I was on the committee uh I I support
the
the movement of the of the art I think
there was ample evidence given that this
audit was required
one hadn't been done in a long time and
that uh
because of the circumstances this this
was essential
thank you all right since there is some
dissension we'll do a roll call
clerk will call a role
the motion is to approve the performance
audit
for
Commission of Human Rights
representative Edwards
yes workloads yes leishman uh
representative Excuse me yes
representative wellner yes
Senator gray yes Senator Bradley no
uh Senator Birdsall no
Senator Rosenwald yes
Senator double Sandro yes Senator Weiler
yes
the the vote is
eight to two
orders eight to two the motion passes
moving on to tab five
we have a consent calendar
with one item on it
Department of military Affairs and
Veterans Services authorizing to
transfer 114
604 in federal General funds through
June 30th 2023. do you want to ask which
items come up with this first here this
on five we've just done the one item
and it's
a fiscal item 23-020
may I ask there'll be a question
yes sure is this on consent
it is so it's it's a decision of the the
chair if they want to move the whole
consent calendar and just pull those
items off that have questions or if they
want to move tap by tab so I'd leave
that to uh chairman Weiler
so I thought it just applied to the one
on Tab five it applies to all the ones
from the airline down it uh so if tabs
five through I believe it's 10 are all
on the consent calendar the previous
committee uh I think it's probably the
first time it had the previous committee
what they would do is then move the
entire consent calendar minus the items
that any member wants to pull off so the
first thing would be if there's any
items on the consent that members would
like to pull off so they can ask the
agencies questions to Just note those
all right so
what I've been told of members take a
look at your agendas
someone asked to withdraw 23022
who asked for that
that's been withdrawn
to have six
oh that no that item was withdrawal that
was withdrawn so there isn't there is no
item that's correct
all right
Tab 7 23001
Senator Rosenwald I have your request
that's off consent
moving on
under tab seven
item
23008 request by representative Edwards
off consent
moving on to item 23025
off consent by representative erf
item number fis23031
is off consent by representative Edwards
and representative erf
you got it
I didn't have any I didn't have any
requests on 026
that remains on consent
all right
23032 representative erf
uh FIS
23033 Representatives leash and Earth
leachmann and Earth
oplc
and under Tab 8 FIS 23036
representative Earth
and
I'll come later to the American Rescue
plan groups
okay
23024 you wish
the 10 10.
well that that's under the uh oh that's
already off
I need to check that out no I haven't
come to Tab 10 yet that's I said I'm
just going ahead with the consent
calendar until we get to American Rescue
plan then I'll take up a separate
consent calendar all right
so
move to acceptance
well is there a motion to accept the
rest of the consent calendar
three moves so to clarify Mr chair yes
when you say the rest you are excluding
Tab 10 at this point are you not I'm
excluding tab 10. all right come to that
later so so the the prior tabs minus the
line items that you've read off that's
what's that's that's what the vote is
thank you sir okay
all in favor of the approving the rest
of the consent calendars say aye opposed
no
appears to be unanimous
Senator Gray
seconded by I think Senator Rose Senator
Dallas Andrew
field all right
so
looks like
FIS 23020 Department of military Affairs
and Veterans that's been approved 021
has been approved o22 has been withdrawn
so now we come to item
23001 Department of Education is there
someone here from the Department of
Education commissioner edelblue
to answer questions
for the record Frank edelblue
Commissioner of Education
Tammy Vaillancourt CFO for education
Senator Rosenwald is recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon
um of of the 1.6 million dollars that we
appropriated in 2019 how much has been
sent out to school districts
and second part of the question is what
is the Department's plan to move the
rest of the money to Abate lead
great thank you for that question so of
the 1.6 million which was approved I
believe actually it was even earlier
than that in 2018
we've spent 74 930 dollars we have three
uh schools that have submissions that
are pending with Des for approval that
will be sent over to us and we'll be
bringing those to you
um and then so the that is how we've
used the funds so far in some respects
that's actually a good thing which means
that we have tested for lead and we've
not found lead in the school system so
we've not needed all of those funds to
remediate lead in the schools as you
know last year in the legislative
session they changed the the
requirements for the testing from 15
parts per million to or billion to five
parts per billion
um those testing results will be coming
back to us between now and June of 2024
so we do think it's prudent to leave the
funding on the book so as we've lowered
those standards there may be additional
schools that are seeking
um you know some support in terms of
remediating any LED in their schools
further thank
Care Centers have any applied or is the
department reaching out to them to
try and bring them on board to do the
testing and Remediation yeah so that the
it is available to Child Care Centers
um the question might be better directed
to someone from Des the Des is the ones
who collects the samples and they submit
them to us for the reimbursement process
and so we're kind of on the back end of
that
um so I don't know the answer but I can
get the answer for you in terms of any
child care centers that have taken
advantage of the program coming right
behind you
there we go
provide a quick answer Cynthia cleven's
New Hampshire Des engineering section
this particular funding is only
available for schools both private and
public schools because it was uh the
application was by the Department of
Education only
I'll I'll follow up on that because my
understanding is that child care centers
were included in the the opportunity
thank you
further questions
motion to accept
23001 made by Senator Rosenwald second
by
Senator Birdsell
any further discussion on the item
seeing Nani ready for the question all
in favor say aye aye opposed no
appears unanimous
all right moving on to
the next removed item
be under tab seven
twenty three zero zero eight
good afternoon members of the committee
Nathan white DHHS CFO
and we welcome Health and Human Services
introduce yourself
good afternoon members of community
thank you Mr chair
uh I I was I was just trying to
understand uh the uh cash flow part of
this because we've merged in this
language both cash benefits and medical
benefits and so I can understand how a
cash benefit might go to an individual
Refugee or their family but how how do
we process the payments for medical care
I don't think this goes through Medicaid
we're not reimbursing Medicaid how how
does this money end up flowing
eventually to the provider
foreign
thank you for that question
representative Edwards um you're correct
it doesn't
go through our these these individuals
are eligible for Medicaid but then if
their earnings exceed and that would go
through our regular channels and if
their earnings are exceed um what makes
them and causes them to be ineligible
for Medicaid then they are eligible for
the um
the cash assistance under the Met under
the Medicaid I mean I'm sorry under the
medical assistance I'm not entirely sure
and I can get back to you on the exact
process unless you are on how they
receive that money it was my
understanding
um through vendors that pay the
providers but I need to check on that I
I would appreciate that I'm just looking
for what the internal controls are
around the on the workflow the process
of getting the money to the provider
that's all and then a second question
for me follow up now uh I I have heard
that our the refugees or guests of our
country are prohibited from working
seeking official employment uh is that
the case can these individuals go get
jobs and maybe come off of the the
welfare role
yes absolutely we um these individuals
are coming in and looking for employment
their supportive employment programs
through some of our vendors with that we
give other funds to to help with job
employment and and case manage their
ability
um and we track all that information so
as as they as stated if they become
ineligible during because of earnings
they are no longer require this
assistance
uh thank you Mr chair thank you for the
question or the answers
thank you very much
further questions from committee members
I'd like to move the item
representative Edwards moves the item
and Senator gray seconds
for the discussion seeing none you ready
for the question all in favor say aye
I pose no
item is it
next item will be 23025
still under tab seven
request by representative erf for a
question same group of people Health and
Human Services
thank you Mr chairman and thank you all
um I'm just learning this process now so
I failed to take note of the fact that
you'd already give me a great answer to
this question this morning so I won't
bother you to um unless you want me to
read it back I don't won't bother you
repeat it but thank you
thank you and for the record my name is
Patricia Tilley I'm the director of
Public Health Services thank you
representative move to approve
Motion in a second to approve item 23025
further discussion from committees
seeing Nani ready for the question all
in favor say aye
oppose no
that motion is adopted
next we'll move on to 0
23031 still under tab 7.
31.
and I I see questions again by
representative erf
31 then as representative Edwards and
irf I had both of you down
representative Edwards is recognized for
a question I I I'm I'm not really
opposed to this uh but I I do think the
public kind of needs to understand what
we're doing here we're taking 318 if I
understand this right we're taking 318
000 because the people who are currently
enrolled in WIC know they're in WIC are
under leveraging their WIC benefits so
we're going to take 318 000 to pay a
contractor who's not going to provide
any food but that contractor is going to
tell the existing WIC people go use your
WIC card I it's a bit of a Layman
description but is it accurate
um thank you representative Edwards I I
would not characterize it as fully
accurate the the points you're making
are correct yes we're bringing in money
we are using those funds in help make
sure that all of our WIC participants
understand how to use their benefits
um WIC is unlike snap for example we
don't just give a blank dollar amount
there is a prescription essentially made
for everyone who participates because in
essence not only is it to provide
supplemental food it's also for the
nutrition education that goes with it
that's what makes it different than a
cash assistance program it really is to
make sure in this particular vulnerable
population pregnant women young children
that they have the food that they need
that meets their Developmental and
growth needs so with these funds we've
noticed
that folks are not utilizing all of
their WIC benefits that could be in part
because we've had additional SNAP
benefits over the public health
emergency and so folks may not feel the
need to use all of the more prescriptive
WIC benefits as we end the public health
emergency we want to make sure that
people know the benefits that they have
how to navigate through the stores to
find what they need and ultimately to
get the nutrition nutrient dense food
that that is appropriate for them and
their children
follow
up so I always appreciate your your
added Precision thank you you just made
New Hampshire smarter okay so so my next
question is is there something that
backs up the 318 is the right amount I
mean why why isn't it 220 000 why isn't
it 450 000. how do we assess the need to
be three hundred and eighteen thousand
dollars sure this is a formula from the
universe Forum USDA and so these are the
funds that were and this is what's
available to us and so we back up and
say what's appropriate for New Hampshire
in that but it was a formula funded
decision at the federal level
further questions from any Committee
Member
is there a motion to approve
representative Edwards moves to approve
representative Dallas Senator Dallas
Andrew seconds
further discussion
seeing none all in favor say aye oppose
no
31 is adopted 32 is somewhat the same
thing and I had that removed by
representative erf
and as before I noted this morning that
you was something a great answer so that
I really appreciate that thank you move
to approve if that's okay
motion approved by representative Earth
second by Senator Gray
further discussion
seeing none all in favor say aye aye
and he posed that motion is also adopted
office of professional licensure and
certification
item number 23033
good afternoon
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee for the record I'm Lindsay
Courtney executive director office of
professional Ace insurance certification
Heather Kelly director of operations
Senator leishman recognized for a
question
did I get it wrong again
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
hearing today
so I had a number of questions
with your request under the
administration division you show uh
salaries temporary employees that's on
the second page this current budget of
zero and it's going to 354 thousand
dollars
and you can kind of carry that through
down to the division of Licensing below
you have another salary temporary
employees it's going from zero to a
hundred and ninety two thousand dollars
and yet on the back page I believe it's
page five
you list 21 new positions it says but
they're existing positions so I'm a
little confused where it says existing
but you've got this additional money and
if we didn't approve this request we'd
be returning about 1.4 million dollars
to the general fund so I was hoping for
an explanation Mr chairman thank you
absolutely thank you representative for
the question so
um just to take a step back oplc has
really two broad initiatives that we're
working on that are rather time
sensitive the first and I think you've
all probably read the audit from the
board of dental examiners
um and recognize uh what we know in the
office which is that there's been a
complete lack of internal controls at
the board level as well as the agency
levels so we have prioritized
establishing internal controls
and that is a project that we're working
on expeditiously which leads into our
second initiative that was also
recognized by the audit which is that
the current technology operated by the
office which is an Enterprise solution
does not meet the state's needs so
recently governor and Council approved a
new contract to procure a new solution
and we will be migrating over the next
two years with a new solution the issue
is that we don't want to migrate bad
data we don't want to migrate improper
information one of my observations has
been that years ago when our technology
was set up it was not the requirements
were not correct they have been modified
over many years to not be consistent
with statute and rules and so as part of
our internal controls project we are
reviewing an inventory in all statutory
and regulatory requirements for both the
agency but as well as our boards in the
mean in order to meet the time frames to
migrate clean information and correct
information over to the new system this
requires this is a significant project
that requires additional support from a
temporary nature
because we have to continue operations
as is while we're focused on basically
our cleanup project
so what we did is we established some
eight T positions that are temporary up
to 52 weeks that do not that are not
required to go before fiscal
um we have not obviously filled the
positions yet this request is to seek
transfer funds or basically budget and
expense so we have Appropriations for
those positions I don't anticipate
um
requiring it's not it's not yet known
whether we will require these positions
beyond the 52 weeks if we do then
obviously we will seek to convert them
to 90s which will require that we bring
this request before the committee to
create the positions but at that time
that's That's the basis for the request
further question Mr chairman for the
question thank you
you also show agency income up about 350
000 is that business is up so to speak
or are you assessing new fees
we are not assessing new fees um so the
income so as as the committee knows oplc
is self-funded
um we have not significantly modified
any fees because there's been a lack of
Clarity over who has statutory statutory
authority to modify thieves as between
the boards and the agencies so we've
worked with the legislature there was a
there was a Committee created last year
to look at that issue and and there's
Bill pending that would resolve that so
we have not made any significant changes
regarding fees the concern has been
always that some boards are meeting
their costs some boards are incredibly
exceeding their costs and some boards
are not meeting their costs the result
of that is that the agency historically
has lacked significant funds to the
general fund 2016 it was 4.8 million
dollars 2017 it was 5.6 2018 it was 5.5
2019 we didn't last any money due to a
statutory change that converts our lapse
to every biennium last year or 2020 we
left seven million approximately for two
years and last year he laughs about four
million dollars so essentially we're
just we carried over funds from last
year we have the funds we don't have the
Appropriations so there hasn't been an
increase in funding it's just utilizing
existing funding available to us
thank you thank you Mr chairman
patina motion to prove the item
motion to approve from representative
lieschman second by Senator gray further
discussion any questions on the item
seeing none you're ready for the vote
all in favor say aye
opposed no
emotion is adopted
next one off consent is
23036 Department of Environmental
Services by representative erf
tab a
representative erf is is recognized for
a question on
23036 from Department of Environmental
Services
uh thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question actually I had
several questions that you'll that you
already answered but since I have you
here I'll just ask another one what
relationship does this funding
bear to the Wastewater funding that we
put into the budget
are you referring to the
the waters revolving Loan program what
is apparently colloquially known as Buco
bucks
the general fund portion
the state a grant program the SAG
program
is and after the fact general fund grant
program to
municipalities for a 20 percent share of
The Debt Service on major upgrades to
their wastewater treatment systems
and that 20 Grant is based on debt
service
after accounting for any grants that
they have received on the front end of
the project
so for instance if there was a town that
had a 10 million dollar project they
received five million dollars from rural
development they received a grant of two
million dollars from us their debt net
Debt Service is three million dollars we
would pay 20 on that debt service
and that would be on an annual basis per
Debt Service payment
and this is some part of that no
what this is is this is a Federal grant
program on the front end of the program
to help municipalities fund the um the
changes either in urging contaminants
to deal with that or in this case we
were given additional money from EPA to
award loans to municipalities
thank you
move to approve
motion to approve by representative
Earth second by Senator bird cell for
the questions from committee members on
the item seeing none are you ready for
the question all in favor say aye
any opposed and motion at figure that
item is adopted
we'll go past item tab nine we'll come
to tab ten which is
the list another consent calendar on
American Rescue plan dollars
and I have some of them have been asked
to be removed the first one is
[Music]
um
trying to remember was it representative
leishman that asked for this
and okay and
the other item in that list is 23030
a request by Senator Rosenwald
so I'll entertain a motion
yeah tab 10. so it's I think we had 24
as well
okay I missed that thank you who asked
that to be removed
okay e
H yeah all right so we removing zero
zero nine zero two four and zero three
zero
move the remaining items
motion and a second Senator Grace
Senator D'Alessandro to approve the the
rest of the consent calendar remaining
further discussion seeing Nani ready for
the question all in favor say aye aye
any opposed
that the rest of the calendar is adopted
and we're moving on to
FIS
23009 Health and Human Services
see Mr lippman
good afternoon
representation recognized for a question
thank you Mr chairman
thank you for appearing
so
um I did receive a response to my
question concerning the liquify liquid
damages the MCO liquid damages
in your response that could lead to a
one thousand dollar penalty per
occurrence which kind of caught my
attention because you got 1.4 million
dollars in that on that line so it seems
like are there that many penalties that
you need to set aside 1.4 million
dollars
thank you for the question
representative um for the record Henry
Littman the state's Medicaid director
the just to give you some sense of skill
the Medicaid Managed Care contract you
know with currently the price limitation
under the current version is over 1.3
billion dollars
we have a very large set of performance
standards and
we monitor them on a monthly basis and
so when when there is an opportunity
that they're not meeting what they're
required to do then we apply it it's a
it's considered a remedy because there's
really the the standards defined and if
they don't meet it then we just collect
it subsequently
thank you Mr chair and thank you
any further questions from any Committee
Member
seeing none
promotion by Senator Bradley second by
senator
Gray
are you ready for the question all in
favor say aye
I pose no
zero zero nine is adopt thank you
we'll next look at
zero twenty three zero two four
again Department of Health and Human
Services
and representative erf and
representative Edwards
representative Edwards you wish to go
first
yes sir that's fine uh okay I want to go
into the weeds uh for a moment
um on the third page
on the class zero three seven
it's for the tablets
and I one I want to thank you for
enumerating that there are 13 of them in
previous submissions and prior years the
quantity was often uh sort of obfuscated
and we couldn't really tell so I
appreciate the specificity thank you
um
what what I'm asking about is this fifty
thousand dollars are are are we
anticipating that these tablets are
essentially disposable or are we going
to be uh including them in the permanent
inventory of of the state and they're
going to be on a maintenance plan we're
going to rotate them or replace them
over time
very much for that question again for
the record Patricia Tilley director of
Public Health so thanks representative
Edwards as noted we have a number of
tablets here that we want to make
available to the 10 County Jail systems
as well as the three State Correctional
Facility so that's the total of the 13
that we're talking about
um in terms of what their lifespan it's
it is not anticipated that this
particular pot of money will continue to
support those odd infant items that
these are being given and provided to
each of the correctional facilities to
ensure that they have access to the
technology they need for the
correctional officers to get the
Infectious Disease training that is
required or that is needed and certainly
has been an added need throughout
covid-19 the state facilities will
likely have a certain plan for
disposition the county facilities will
likely have a different plan for
disposition that you know in terms of
the way that those function for the
purposes of this grant this is a one and
done we're going to give them these
tablets we want to make sure that these
that this training occurs over the next
couple of years okay so it's a small
amount of money and I'm not I'm not
obsessing on a small amount of money I'm
just trying to make sure that there's a
consistent principle that when we do a
one-time investment with Federal money
that we're aware of what the long-term
maintenance tail is and if that
maintenance tail is the obligation of
the general funds or not I don't believe
that this would be the obligation of the
general funds okay thank you and then
the in-person training described in 37
is probably much narrower than what will
really happen it just talks about
there'll be uh training on prevention of
covid-19 I think you implied it's a
broader topic on infectious diseases
correct yes correct it'll be a broader
topic it's across all infectious
diseases inclusive of covid-19 and this
is really going to be a train the
trainer model so there'll be some in
person but the tablets are really there
so that those people that get the
trainer training can go and share that
with their colleagues back in their own
facilities so so thank you for that one
one of the reasons I I sometimes will
pick something so narrow and and dig
into it is is just to test whether or
not the department is on its toes and
actually doing its homework and you you
never you never fail so thank you thank
you Mr chair
entertain a motion to approve the item
all right wait representative erf has a
question
thank you Mr chair
and thank you both
I had some questions and you did answer
them but I have another one that kind of
ties into those questions
um can you speak to the racial and
ethnic Health disparities mentioned here
occurring in our prisons and Rural
locations sure so
there are these funds which are funds
that were accepted uh a while back now
you know 18 months ago or so
um was really designed for not only
racial and ethnic Health disparities but
Health disparities across the board and
so incarcerated individuals are
considered one of those people that have
a disparate outcome and disparate impact
of covid-19 so I don't know the racial
ethnic breakup of the incarcerated
population but just by the means that
they are in that congregate setting
where it's really hard to manage
infectious diseases they are at higher
risk for Contracting infectious diseases
not only among the population of
residents that are in those facilities
but also among the staff we work very
closely with our all of our Correctional
Facilities County and the state systems
to help them manage and mitigate those
risks because it's very different than
say a health care facility or you know
any other facility where people have a
little bit more ownership you could wear
masks there's really some special need
in these in in these places
I follow up follow up
thank you for that I might suggest that
when you write these things up you're a
little clear about what you write since
it was pretty clear that you were
talking about racial and ethnic Health
disparities I didn't just pull that out
of the air great but thank you no I
appreciate that question and I'll just
let the committee know just today the
federal government accountability office
the GAO submitted a report on this
particular funding source where they did
a deep dive in five States including New
Hampshire about the types of work that
is going on with them so I'm happy to
share that if the committee is
interested
motion to approve
representative Earth moves to approve I
think it was Senator Bradley or
Senator gray moved to a second
further discussion any more questions
from the committee members seeing Nani
ready for the question all in favor of
adopting the Amendments adopting the
items say aye
opposed no
it is adopted
next one I have is FIS 23030
and it was request of Senator Rosenwald
Department of Health and Human Services
thank you Mr chairman
chairman of several
questions you may go ahead thank you so
this item seems to
start some new programs or expand some
programs
using federal funds
um
like the homeless Health Care Program
is the department planning to put years
two and three into the budget
after we accept this money for starting
with year one in fiscal
or will
I guess the rest of that question is at
the end of arpa funds will we be
expecting to see these as ongoing budget
requests
so I I will answer the first question
again Nathan white DHHS CFO at this
point in time based on the guidance that
we received the Statewide guidance that
we received back this back in this
during the summer in August when we put
our agency budget requests together we
we had kept those
um the the one-time Federal money the
arpa funds and other funds outside of
our standard agency budget request
however you know if at the legislative
phase or whatever brings about through
the governor's budget there was a desire
to include that in in the the
overarching budget we will certainly do
so
um as far as the long term
um I mean ultimately that would be
dependent upon whether funds would be
available to continue these these
programs
thank you
um so
the 30 million dollars in Workforce
Investments I see that's a one-time
retention bonuses or
um something like that is the department
going to include other Workforce
Investments like Medicaid rate increases
in its budget requests
are we going to include Medicaid budget
rate increases in our budget request is
it uh yes so in our agency budget
request you'll see our efficiency budget
as well as our prioritized needs column
and we included a number of
Medicaid rate increases off the top of
my head I believe we had 20 million
dollars for General Medicaid uh in the
LTT LD dltss we had included an
additional budget rate increase we had
included an additional prioritized need
request to align the adult Dental fee
schedule with the children's fee
schedule as well so there are a number
of
prioritized needs requests that we did
include in our budget when we submitted
that back in September thank you and one
more if I could I see that
um you want to fund presumptive
eligibility for CFI
with two million dollars we've we've had
presumptive eligibility for CFI on the
books
for 15 years in New Hampshire we've
never funded it my understanding is
there's no guarantee of a retroactive
payment and that state general funds
would be on the hook
if the person was later found ineligible
I'm assuming that's still true but for
15 years we haven't funded it in fact
when the governor presented his budget
to the legislature two years ago
he asked to repeal this program in house
bill 2. we worked in the Senate phase to
suspend it why that why the change of
heart
after 15 years why has the department
come on board sure hi my name is Melissa
Hardy I'm the division director for
long-term supports and services thank
you for your question in our most recent
submission to CMS for the arpa spending
plan we've actually changed from
presumptive eligibility to Diversion
knowing those facts that you just stated
and also as far as needing a one one
five waiver in order to do presumptive
eligibility so I think there was a link
in the fiscal item to our most recent
updated spending plan that's been
approved by CMS to actually change from
presumptive eligibility to Diversion
meaning providing
community-based supports to non-medicaid
folks such as home health aides Meals on
Wheels in order to keep them in the
community longer versus
institutionalization
final follow-up so on page
I don't know
um where you
request two million dollars for
presumptive eligibility is that in
you're not requesting that correct we we
have changed our um approach with these
dollars and is now changing it to
um the diversion process so presumptive
eligibility is not in our spending plan
okay and and just as a point of clarity
um the the prior item is included in
this and when we submit the new item we
attach all the documentation that was
included in the prior item we we tried
to correct for that by including that
link that Melissa had referenced there
but that's that's why you're seeing that
old language attached to the full
complete item there in front of you
thank you
thank you Mr chair
if
the item when you submit it is a little
clearer we won't need as many questions
so obviously she found something that
wasn't clearly spelled out that should
have been done so we didn't need to
prolong this
and and ask all these questions because
it obviously wasn't explained in the
item
we're hoping for better communication in
the future any motion to approve the
item
second motion by Senator Rosenwald
second by Senator gray to approve item
further questions from the committee
members seeing none you're ready for the
question all in favor say aye
opposed no that is adoption
moving on to the regular calendar on Tab
11.
first item
23035 Department of Health and Human
Services division of finance and
procurement
any discussion on this I think I see
some questions both from the Senate and
from representative erf I think you are
no you had no questions on this one all
right any Senator any Senator had a
question there was some indication from
the LBA that the senate had some
question on this
Senator Rosenwald is recognized I think
I had a couple of questions on page
four in the ABD grants aptd grants the
case you say that case loads
are not back to pre-covered levels and
I'm wondering if that is because
we're having trouble getting
determinations
made or because
you can't we can't find the direct
service providers
to provide this service once the
determinations are made how why are
those
caseloads not back
the acquired brain disorders
the decrease
kind of have Chris sentinelo joined me
to answer that question
good afternoon Chris Antonello associate
commissioner can you repeat the question
I'm sorry so the APD
caseloads are not back to pre-covered
levels yeah
to what extent is that because we can't
get the determinations done
and to what extent is it because once
the determinations are done there
there's a lack of care providers to
deliver the services well aptd is a cash
payment so it wouldn't be reliant on
care providers but I can go back and
look at our most recent statistics
because we do track how many people are
pending I just don't have that with me
okay could I but I will get that to you
so on page
12.
um
under system of care
could you tell us why
um
we've had delays in residential
treatment contract approvals
and have not been able to stand up the
programs we've funded
sure
um I mean Katya Fox is going to join me
here I I believe kacho will probably
speak to General capacity issues but go
right ahead
so good afternoon I'm Katya Fox I'm the
director of the division for Behavioral
Health and the you're going to see
repeatedly that we do have delays where
appropriated funds that start July 1st
well of course we have to go through
quite a process to get those funds
approved and that includes contracts and
we have contracts currently for
children's residential treatment I
believe we have 46 programs and so we're
Contracting extensively and therefore by
the time we we get those into place time
has passed and so not as many funds are
needed or used also you also will note
that Staffing capacity is a huge issue
so the use of the any housing and
treatment specifically for treatment
the capacity is not the full amount that
we contract for so therefore
there are funds still available
thank you further questions yes on same
page that community mental health
programs support there's uh the
contracts
contract obligations have been less than
anticipated due to delay of supported
housing expansion where do we stand on
Contracting
the second tranche of the supported
housing beds that we've funded three or
four years ago
so again thank you for that question I
do want to note that yes we we are
transferring funds from this area
and because of the lack of our ability
to stand up some beds but we have in
that in the meantime between State
fiscal year 21 and 22 we still were able
to stand up 52 Beds which is pretty
significant considering the challenges
in the housing market and with Staffing
so I can get you the breakdown of where
that growth has come and what types of
beds because a bed is not a bed we have
transitional housing we have drf beds we
have
permanent Supportive Housing so there
are a number of different areas and it's
just not you know beds so so I can get
you the breakdown of that but that is a
reality is again the delays in
Contracting and providers ability to be
able to stand up these funds we have a
really as you know are really tight
housing market and in order for them to
stand up they have to have housing stock
and the ability to to have that property
as well is we have a our housing Bridge
subsidy program which is provides a
bridge until someone can get on to a
Housing Voucher housing Choice voucher
and what has happened is that even
though we have a number of people who've
been approved for those vouchers and for
that bridge they have been unable to
secure housing so we have about 25
percent of the people who have been
approved are still out seeking an
apartment
final follow-up if I could
um thank you for mentioning drf bets
because I know that in the last year the
fiscal committee approved some money to
add to our stock of drf beds how many
new drf beds have we contracted for with
the money we approved
so I would need to know what time frame
you're looking at and then I can get
back to you with the money we approved
last year I'll have to get back to you
on on that um as you know again uh
Workforce has been a huge challenge in
being able to staff our beds thank you
thank you Mr chair
any further questions from a Committee
Member on item number 23035
seeing not only entertain a motion to
accept
Senator rosenwal moves to adopt the item
Senator D'Alessandro seconds further
discussion seeing nania ready for the
question all in favor say aye I pose no
item 23035 is adopted
moving on to
tab 12.
transformed for a New Hampshire Fish and
Game department move the item
representative leishman moves to adopt
Senator bird sells seconds further
discussion seeing none
you need it yes I further discussion
I tried to jump on you all right Senator
Earth has a question for fish
representative representative
Senate is over here representative
okay representative erf has a question
for fish and game
um
good afternoon Scott Mason executive
director at New Hampshire Fish and Game
good afternoon Diane Timmons Inland
Fisheries division Chief overseer of
hatcheries and whatnot
good afternoon
representative erf is recognized for a
question uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my questions I have two
questions
we're very very related
could you give me date certain when
online
renewals will be complete and also when
online new registrations will be
complete
I believe that's in the next item oh my
the wrong I apologize
I spelled out the next police so you're
you're referencing our uh ohrv online
registration request my bad
sure okay so we're at we're at item
number 23014 we have a motion to accept
in a second further discussion seeing
none all in favor say aye pose no
item FIS
23014 is adopted
hang on
13 item 23015 and we have the right
people here I think
director
just a slight switch up in the team
there was a question both from
representative erf and as in a senator
Senator Bradley
representative erf question
thank you Mr chair and Senator Bradley I
think you heard my questions and they
haven't changed the date certain for
implementation of
renewal registrations and then
apparently separately for new
registrations
um
what we originally negotiated with the
snow machine in the ATV State
organizations in the legislature was to
have online renewals up and running by
September of 25 once we have that
program up and running and working
successfully we will then add new
registrations to that
follow-up
so this is based on a bill and maybe I
misread it and I think you actually
quoted it in your fiscal note I thought
everything was supposed to be done by
September of 25.
um it's our interpretation that what we
agreed to was uh uh renewals by 25 and
then new registrations immediately
afterwards
there was a question that was brought to
Captain Eastman asking if we could
change the language in the bill so that
they wouldn't have to come back after we
did renewals for a separate bill and we
agreed to that and unfortunately it's
created some ambiguity into when we were
going to develop
renewals and and new registrations
so one last question when you say
immediate the new will be available
immediately after as soon as we can you
know we have to develop the system and
and get it up and running so can you
quantify that in terms of time months
weeks years
um
I can't just because this will be the
first time uh I've been part of the
development of a system
um the online
um license sales for hunting and fishing
licenses took several years to develop
the whole program and get it up and
running and and going
um hopefully we'll be moving faster I
think the industry has certainly gone to
more online
venues and I'm hoping that our Service
Partners will be able to help us move
forward more quickly part of the issue
is is that we are revamping a lot of our
computer systems at Fish and Game Online
registrations is just one of them the
legislature has created a other
requirement for us to have online deer
registration in 24. online ATV
registration in
25. we have picked up there was a bill
passed um 10 or 12 years ago that
created it's part of a interstate
compact that we that the state of New
Hampshire joined uh so when you violate
a hunting a fishing license you will not
be able to buy a license in any of the
participating States this is something
that would that the state of New
Hampshire agreed to tend to is either 10
or 12 years ago so that program we're
trying to get up and running for us too
and at the same time we've that came
through here last session we've received
a go for Grant to upgrade our database
systems so in the next couple of years
we're going to have most of our folks
involved in doing a bunch of different
computer upgrades thank you
Senator gray or Senator Bradley has a
question next
um I think representative very fast most
of my questions but I I guess I'd follow
up on a why is it taking so long as I
recall when we did the voluntary hike
Safeguard which you administer and do a
really good job of it
um happened a lot sooner and quicker and
it's very easy yeah the hike safe crowd
we think I believe that was a much
easier program to get up and running
part of the problem here
right now when you come to register a
machine
um you the process obviously you show up
physically at a location whether it be
headquarters or one of our agents pay
your money register your machine you
receive the registration sticker so we
have to set all of that that programming
up to
and it will be going through rule making
there'll be quite a few steps for us to
get the process up and running
Senator gray for a question uh actually
more of a statement I've got several
constituents along with several Senators
that are very interested in this so when
you come before Finance in the Senate I
would hope that you'll bring along an
update on this and how that relates to
your budget items so we appreciate that
okay thank you
representative Edwards for a question uh
thank you uh thank you uh Mr chairman
thank you director Mason
um my my good friend and colleague uh
representative James Spillane uh emailed
you on Wednesday morning
um I I I'm not looking for an answer to
the question but you're gonna you're
gonna answer him okay I figured you
would uh and he points out that
fb1554 a few years ago said that all
registration must be done by September
125. am I hearing you say that we're not
going to meet that date or we will but
we're going to do it in phases
uh is that the right
Captain Michael Eastman a conservation
officer law enforcement uh with I'm
actually the coordinator for ohrv
enforcement registrations and safety uh
I believe what he was what
representative display was speaking
about was uh RSA 215a uh 45 and 215 c59
and those are actually the laws that
were that went along with um with
creating this online system what those
say
um in our interpretation of them and
what the intent of when and I was a
large part of this was that
we agreed to the renewal program and
what the law says is that we would that
the executive director would
basically put together what the
proceedings for that would be or what
the process would be for that
um and not that that the process would
be
renewals and knew that it was actually
the renewal program and that that
processes that came together and that's
the whole workings from going online and
getting it or doing the registration and
then receiving it
afterwards is that process so therefore
the law does does not specifically say
that it has to be both I mean it's our
intent in the down the road that that
would happen
um
follow-up so I I guess I'm kind of also
just looking for a yes or no September 1
2025 is the deadline I understand that's
what made it into law
for all registrations are are we going
to meet that deadline are we going to
get there in phases are we going to be
late I'm just looking for project status
not the whole detail
um at this point I would say that we
will have a renewal online done by
September of 25 and then we as I say we
will move into original registrations
probably post
925. all right so so all right mayor it
recommend some public messaging this is
one of the few things where I'm already
getting hate mail from constituents so
I'm really glad that it's not in DHHS it
kind of gives me something different to
think about thank you
representative
I'd just like to read the law
it states
the executive director Xiao no later
than September 1st 2025
establish any procedures that may be
necessary
to enable the online payment of
registration fees required or imposed
under this chapter
and I've been getting like others I
guess mail from folks not just regarding
our constituents in New Hampshire but
apparently we're the only state in
Northern New England that doesn't have
this available so out of state people
tend to go to Vermont and Maine even
Massachusetts because they can basically
pop online register their machine and go
snowmobiling whereas they can't do that
and come to New Hampshire which means
we're losing as I understand it I'm not
a snowmobile this I'm not an expert but
we're losing uh tourist dollars thank
you
Mr
Dallas Andrew
I too have been receiving uh
notices about this problem about the
registration I think it's becoming a
significant issue
as to as to when it's going to be done
uh and and how it's going to be done and
there are those who believe you have the
ability to do it now
and it is is that the case uh why is it
being stalled I don't believe we do have
the ability to do it now because we have
other uh other issues that are facing
the department that are requiring us to
move forward on as I said we're trying
to come into compliance with a law that
was passed 10 or 12 years ago on hunting
and fishing licenses and we also have to
come into compliance with the law on
deer registration
for the point follow up I understand
that and I appreciate that
but indeed
if this isn't on your priority list
and there is a lot there's Lauren place
that says it should be done and people's
perception is that it should be done the
public is is uh is being confused at
this point in time it is on our priority
list but
the legislature has actually put it into
at least third third on our priority
list
not not first
and also as I the other issue is is our
database issue that we're trying to
solve and of course we have the time
constraint on that because it's go for
funding
thank you Mr
and we earlier did approve some other
funds like from northern borders region
to the trails and so on is that any of
that help speed this up
um no that's not the source of the
funding for this
representative leishman for a question
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
appearing today so the question I have
do you not have the adequate funding to
take care of these upgrades or are you
working with like our department of
Information Technology or is this a
contract that you're going to put out to
do these upgrades or well it's a
contract plus that's also internal staff
time
it's the internal staff time that is
probably the largest limiting factor
thank you thank you Mr chairman
any further questions from committee
members seeing none I'll entertain a
motion to adopt 23016
excuse me 23015
1-5 correct
adopt 23015 I've moved on
mobile Senator Bradley second by Senator
Birdsall to adopt 23015.
further discussion seeing Nani ready for
the question all in favor say aye I
opposed no no I'm going to be a no just
because I I think we need some attention
on this
all right eight to two sound accurate
we got to get something right here
all right moving on to FIS 23016
any questions on this
foreign
moves to adopt
is there a second
Senator Bradley seconds further
discussion seeing Nani ready for the
question
all those in favor say aye opposed no
we've adopted 23016.
moving on to item 23038
Senator D'Alessandro moves to adopt
23038 it's seconded by Senator Rosenwald
any further discussion on this item
who was it bird cell
I'm just hearing it from that side I
didn't see which one said it
all right Senator bird silk I'll try to
help
appreciate it
you wanna take a vote all in favor say
aye
I opposed no we have adopted FIS
23038 there is a late item
which you have before you
if you want a little time to look it
over
this is from
emergency relief Governor the Gopher
funds governor's office of emergency
relief and Recovery
it's a request authorized to accept and
expend funds in the amount of three
million 593 328 an American Rescue plan
emergency rental assistance financial
assistance funds for use in the New
Hampshire emergency rental assistance
program effective upon fiscal committee
and governor and Council approval
through June 30 2023 this is an
allowable use of era two funds under
arpa Section 3201
parentheses D to provide financial
assistance to eligible households as
Allowed by U.S treasury to help keep
households stably housed 100 federal
funds
whenever you get through looking at it
I'll entertain a motion to adopt uh Mr
chairman I gotta I have a few questions
well I got to this one
is it Mystic director Caswell to answer
it
sir
uh Taylor Caswell here as director of
gopher and chief sagerman who's our
deputy director
representative Edwards is recognized for
a question uh thank you Mr chair uh good
seeing again director Caswell
um last time we met was not that long
ago and and I asked you a tough homework
problem I asked you if we had any
statistics that would tell us what are
our vacancy rate is on rental units in
New Hampshire
what amount of the total stock is being
consumed by people without any
assistance and what the percentages are
around
how many units are being rented with
rental assistance I posited the theory
that
our vacancy rate is so small that the
supply is so tight that any amount of
money that we put into chasing that
scarce Supply is probably going to have
an abnormal disproportionate
inflationary effect that's all from my
econ 101 40 years ago so so I was asking
you if what you thought of that theory
and if you had any data and so could
could you tell us well I mean I we did
go back and look at if there was any
obvious sort of research or data that
spoke to the issue of
rental subsidy and availability of
rental units anywhere in the United
States there isn't anything that we've
found we have posed that question with
some of our partners at New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority to see if
there is anything out there that can
speak to that at
as I think we mentioned at the time of
our conversation having said that it
the the level of subsidy that comes to
the housing market generally outside of
this program outside of really sort of
any other program that we've talked
about at least that I've been involved
with on the housing side is is
substantial in the United States you
have
subsidies that are for developers
subsidies that are for owners subsidies
that are for
um
uh tenants landlords all fairly
substantial and all mostly at least in
our case here in New Hampshire all
administered and funded by the federal
government so in this case this
particular program was established in
March of 2021 in reaction to the covid
pandemic so these funds are specifically
for a population that I could
demonstrate an impact from covid and in
most cases is assisting those
individuals to stay in the housing that
they were already in
follow up okay so I appreciate this is
really a complex area I'm predisposed to
proving this I I I I I just lose just a
little bit of sleep at night thinking
that in the attempt to do good by
providing rental assistance into a
market that has a very tight scarcity of
vacancies that were we may accidentally
be doing harm to the people that don't
have rental
assistance because their rents will go
up without the kind of help that others
are getting so so just as that's me
telling you I can't sleep well enough
the the the the the part I do want to
tell you about is I've been talking to
Mr Ben Frost yes and uh in the last
couple of days communicated with them
and it seems to me like he understands
the kind of uh problem I'm concerned
about and these researching it and
trying to pull together as much data as
he can so to the extent that you guys
are in communication you know maybe
maybe you can come up with a better
product yeah we we work with them
regularly and I'm aware of that that
effort yes sir all right thank you
Senator Bradley has questions
Senator D'Alessandro has a question
thank you Mr chairman
first of all thanks for coming before us
and with the with the late item
temporary housing where are these are
these people all Hotel people no sir
this that's a separate uh issue as you
know that we've discussed in the past so
these are uh this is the what we call
now the regular emergency rental
assistance program that is administered
by nifa for people who are in housing
already
for the question now when you when you
say in housing already
what housing are we talking about it
could be any type of housing rental
housing in the state that they're that
they're that they apply for funding
under this program through the local cap
um and that that those rents are funded
under this program so uh for for the
question so so could this be uh the
hotel situation
could this I mean could we be paying uh
we could be yes yes okay and just one
last time this is this is situ this is a
situation that has a very finite value
and and the the question is what's next
and when the subsidy disappears that's
that's a problem but where do the people
go to me that's the real problem
I agree and there are uh you know with
this program as we've discussed before
there are a large number of services
that are also funded under this program
that are just for that purpose because
obviously when this program began we
began we began this program back in 2021
with the full knowledge that it was a
finite amount of resource that was going
to be available
plant
thank you Mr chairman
Senator bird cell for a question
thank you
Mr how much of this out this rental
assistant actually goes to the landlords
a good point all of it does
it go directly to the land yes
yes ma'am oh okay thank you
recognize Senator Bradley for a motion
we've got a question first from uh
Senator leishman a representative Alicia
I'll take that a second time that's fine
yeah I thought I'd only make it once
a follow-up if I could to uh Senator
birdsall's question uh what is the
amount of money per individual landlord
do you have like a rough estimate are
they getting
500 a thousand dollars a month and how
many families are affected by this
deputy director at gopher it's a great
question representative
um the amount of money uh amount of
money awarded assistance is is tracked
per household the program is just
structured so that the landlord is
largely almost exclusively paid directly
as opposed to giving the funds to the
tenant to then give it to the landlord
um the assistant assistance number uh
per household has grown over time as you
might expect since it's been going on
for a couple years I believe it's around
between nine and ten thousand dollars on
average per household over the over the
course of the program
a follow-up per household per year per
month on average over the whole program
the pro you max out an assistance at 18
months for the program so it's a per
household over the life of their
eligibility
thank you Mr chairman thank you
okay I have a motion from Senator
Bradley to approve 23041
the second by Senator bird cell further
discussion
seeing none you're ready for the
question all in favor say aye opposed no
item 23041 is adopted
on the
informational materials anybody have any
questions that they want to
call up some group for
Senator Rosenwald on the DHHS dashboard
I have one question okay item 23040 the
dashboard
we have a question
thank you
um on table eight
of the dashboard
um
the adult adults
seen in the community mental health
system
that caseload is still running at
50 percent of pre-pandemic levels
um I know there are a lot of vacancies
in that system but
what are we going to see from the
Department to
increase the number of people who get
treated in the community
before they end up in a full-blown
crisis
stuck in the emergency department
waiting for a bet at the most expensive
most restrictive places
so again for the record I'm Katya Fox
I'm the director of the division for
Behavioral Health the issue of those
numbers has come up previously and I
believe that you raised that that data
is pulled from a financial system and
really fluctuates that's why you see a
dip and then you see an increase based
on invoicing so we are going to be
changing that information we ran the
numbers yesterday with data analytics to
look at the actual numbers that are
through a different system through claim
a different claim system and how we
categorize
the the data coming in and information
coming in you are going to see and I can
provide to the committee
the actual increase in the number of
individuals who've been served in the
last three or four years so you're going
to see an increase not what your
um recognizing in the data and that is
part of the discussions that we've had
about overhauling the entire dashboard
and this is one area that we want to
focus on so I'd be happy to provide that
information that was run yesterday and
are we going to start seeing these
correct numbers soon
so it will probably still be a couple of
months before we have an updated
dashboard capacity is an issue you've
seen our vacancy rates north of 20
percent so finding the time to to devote
to that update has been challenging
however what we do want to do
with the new dashboard is provide more
visual demonstration and charts so that
you're not having to go through each one
of these to come to your own conclusion
that you'll see some more whether it's
pie charts or Trends or graphs with
trend lines it'll be a little bit easier
for everybody to quickly look at that
and pull away the conclusions So within
the coming months but it is certainly an
overhaul in an effort to get that done
thank you
any other questions on the informational
items that the committee wishes to have
answered
all right seeing none
Steve Smith as any of your other audit
people that have been recognized here in
this item
the ncsl
you're the only one
Let's uh
referring us to item 22
429 certificate of impact for the 2019
performance audit of the Adult Parole
Board his recognition by the National
Conference of state legislators
National legislative program evaluation
gave them a certificate of impact
and so
I wish to uh
have us all recognize the performance
audit section for the fine work they do
and finally others have been have been
uh
recognizing it as well so
let's put this on the agenda again in
case some of these people show up
another time
I do I do want to have some recognition
for you staff and I appreciate all the
work you do thank you I'll definitely
pass that along so
so what's that
a lot more credit than I do so all right
so now we move on to the Audits and
recognizing Stephen Smith director of
audits okay
thank you Mr chair I was advised that
going back to the state actor which KPMG
presented admin Services doesn't have
any prepared comments at this time so
unless there's no question any committee
has any questions we can move into the
turnpike
presentation
any questions on any other audits that
we had covered earlier by KPMG
seeing none will move on to the turnpike
audit
which we have already had a motion to
accept place on file and release in the
usual manner so now we're going to have
a little discussion of it
joining me at the table is uh Bob
Mahoney he's the partner with KPMG that
did the turnpike audit and from the
system is Danielle
Chardonnay
chandanae I got close there and Andre
Brier the Deputy Commissioner so I'll
turn it over to uh Mr Mahoney
thanks Steve again for the record Bob
Mahoney ought to partner with KPMG so in
the materials you should have a copy of
the turnpike financial statements as
well as the internal control over
financial reporting and compliance and
other matters also known as the yellow
book report
and lastly the debt compliance letter
I'll first speak to the financial
statement so the opinion on the turnpike
financial statements uh this year was
unmodified also known as a clean opinion
so congratulations to Danielle and her
team for all the hard work that they do
to prepare the financial statements
the opinion indicates that management is
ultimately responsible for the accuracy
of the financial statements and we are
responsible for expressing an opinion on
the financial statements we conducted
our audit in accordance with generally
accepted auditing standards in the U.S
as well as Government auditing standards
um in addition uh the opinion of
references uh the separate report which
I indicated earlier the report on
internal control of financial reporting
and compliance in that report uh you
will see that we did identify one
significant deficiency during the course
of the audit uh related to the turnpike
systems implementation of the gasby 87
lease standard which was new this year
management did not properly reflect the
accounting in the initial draft of the
financial statements related to an
existing ground lease so that was
corrected in the financial statements
that were ultimately issued but we did
identify a significant deficiency
however we did not identify any material
weaknesses and internal control in that
report so you will see that and happy to
answer any questions as well and then
lastly the debt compliance report
um that that report basically indicates
that we review viewed the provisions and
Covenants associated with the bond
resolutions of the turnpike and
determined that the turnpike was in
compliance with the covenants and
Provisions
and lastly I'll just go through some of
the required Communications to the
committee so there were no significant
and unusual transactions during the
course of the audit there was one
uncorrected misstatement which is
consistent with prior years related to
the fact that the trusted opeb liability
does not get allocated to the turnpike
the state records the entire trusted
opeb liability on its financial
statements so that continues to be an
uncorrected misstatement again only 1.1
million dollars that's not allocated to
the turnpike
um as I mentioned no excuse me sure Mr
chair representative Edwards is
oped is is that an acronym and if you're
going to use acronyms for us civilians
could you spell it out the first time
you use it yeah please other
post-employment benefits that's great
thanks and I know what a fast B is and
you but you said that we had a material
weakness on an aspect of it I didn't I
didn't pick it all up sure it was it was
related to The gasby Standard number 87
Gatsby government yes okay yeah the
government Accounting Standards
statement all right thank you sure
um so we did evaluate the significant
accounting policies
um that the turnpike has in place and
determined that they were reasonable uh
there was no fraud or illegal acts that
we identified during the course of the
audit we did not have any disagreements
with management and we did not encounter
any significant difficulties during the
course of the audit either and lastly we
are independent with respect to the
turnpike as well so happy to answer any
questions
um and uh Danielle if you have any
prepared remarks or Andre feel free
Mr chairman members of the committee we
uh as you know our Turnpike system is an
economic engine for the state as such
it's incredibly important for us that
we're transparent and we're following
good accounting practices we appreciate
kpmg's uh audit in fact we we welcome
audits to this system and to to all of
our DOT activities it helps us know
where to focus attention in this case uh
there was one finding what we agree with
and we're we've taken the the steps
necessary to correct that in future
audits
can it wasn't clearly understood this
gaspi 89 which hasn't been in effect
before how does this work this land
lease that had to be
recorded some different way
s
yeah so uh for the first time uh these
leaves this particular ground lease
which is a lessor Arrangement
um ultimately had to get recorded as a
least receivable and Associated deferred
inflow on the face of the balance sheet
within the financial statements for the
first time whereas previously it was
just disclosed in the notes of the
financial statements
um in the the expenditure associated
with you know leases in general are
recorded used to be recorded on the on
the uh Steve of activities or the
statement of revenues and expenses it
wasn't as if it had been deleted it was
just not put in the right section
right essentially it was it wasn't
reflected on the face of the statements
in accordance with the new prescribed
rules under Academy 87.
yes it is it was effective for the
fiscals no rule after you've been filled
out your spreadsheets and said we've
changed our mind you did it wrong
this is tough I pity you
Senator Senator gray for a question
um my question is about the uncorrected
item okay uh who in your department is
doing it uh is it when we are going to
correct or seek other remedy and then
overall for even administrative services
or the LBA
um you know who is tracking these
Statewide so that we're looking at them
before the audits start to see if you
know they are have a timeline to correct
these things and so I'll let you answer
your piece for you for your item and
then I'll hopefully get input either at
this meeting or at other meetings I know
that administrative Services doesn't
seem to be paying attention to me so so
they may get a surprise at the end of
this but
oh
so there was a decision made at the
Statewide level to not to not uh do this
and it's probably something that
uh the desk would speak to uh later it's
not it's not something that the turnpike
system has done or can
do on on their own
uh no it didn't answer the question but
I I think that administrative Services
may want to talk to me afterwards
thank you
further questions on the turnpike audit
system do I did I read in here that your
shortest Turnpike the blue star takes in
the most Revenue
I believe that's true yeah cost the
people of Maine to get through New
Hampshire
that's right we don't mind that
but they don't pay their share of the
bridge
okay I believe it's been moved and
adopted to accept this place on file and
release in the usual manner any other
questions on the turnpike audit
I sympathize with you on that Gatsby
all right
thanks
do we have the Liquor Commission as well
or has that been done
Lottery
Mr chairman next is Lottery Then
followed by the liquor
joining me at the table is uh Kimberly
Bisson she was the manager on this for
our office and also joining us from the
commission is director McIntyre and Jim
durris CFO so that Kim will present the
audit report
[Music]
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record
my name is Kimberly Bisson we're here
today to report the results of our audit
of the financial statements contained in
the New Hampshire Lottery's annual
comprehensive financial report referred
to as the actor for the fiscal year
ended June 30th 2022.
the financial statements begin on page
46 of the report Lottery management is
responsible for the preparation and fair
presentation of these statements in
accordance with generally accepted
accounting principles
our Auditors report an opinion dated
December 19 2022 can be Pat excuse me
found on pages 27 through 30 in the
financial section of the report
as noted in the opinion paragraphs on
page 27 we issued an unmodified or clean
opinion on the Lottery's basic financial
statements which also include the notes
and other supplementary information
while our opinion speaks directly to the
basic financial statements and notes no
matters came to our attention that
caused us to believe that other
Financial
that other information in the financial
section of the report was inconsistent
with the basic financial statements
auditing standards require we make a
number of disclosures to you these
disclosures were previously discussed by
KPMG and are also included in our
required communication handout inserted
into your report
in the interest of time I will not go
through each of them individually
however we can say that we were
satisfied with the cooperation of the
lottery and the progress of the audit
and there is nothing we need to bring to
the committee's attention related to any
concerns with those required disclosures
in accordance with government auditing
standards we'll be issuing a report on
our consideration of the Lottery's
internal control over financial
reporting and on compliance and other
matters as a byproduct of our audit of
the financial statements and that report
will be included in the management
letter which will be presented to this
committee at a future meeting
this concludes my presentation I'd like
to thank Lottery management and staff
for their assistance during the audit
and with your permission I'll turn the
presentation over to director McIntyre
who can provide Management's perspective
on the report thanks
Victor McIntyre Mr chairman good
afternoon members of the fiscal
committee I have the privilege of being
the director of Lottery Charlie McIntyre
and with me is our Chief Financial
Officer Jim Durst is Steve Smith
described um just want to thank the LBA
staff as you folks know we are audited
annually and it's always been a
collaborative and helpful process I just
want to thank Kimberly and the rest of
her team and Steve and his team for
their efforts and certainly welcome any
questions you have Mr chairman members
of the committee
questions from the committee members
congratulations on another great year
director McIntyre yes sir it's our um
third or fourth record year in a roaster
you do good work we try
[Laughter]
I'm pleased with your colorful report
all right we move on to liquor or
yes Mr chairman last uh last audit is uh
the Liquor Commission also performed by
our office
and joining me is Jim levera he's the
manager on this audit and from the
commission chairman Malika and the CFO
Tina Demers
so Jim will present our audit report
good afternoon chairman weilers and
members of the committee again for the
record my name is Jim larvier
we are here today to report the results
of our audit of the financial statements
contained in the New Hampshire Liquor
commissions annual comprehensive
financial report for the fiscal year
ended June 30th 2022.
our Auditors report an opinion dated
December 20th 2022 can be found on pages
11 through 14 in the financial section
of the report
as noted in the opinion paragraph on
page 11 the financial statements are
presented fairly in all material
respects in accordance with generally
accepted accounting principles
an important item to note is no material
adjustments to the accounting records
were proposed as a result of our audit
similarly
and what you heard earlier from KPMG for
a turnpike's audit due to the state's
decision not to flow the New Hampshire
retirement system sub-trust other
post-employment benefit expense and
liability down to the Enterprise fund
financial statements
we identified a significant but not
Material uncorrected misstatement
understating the liquor commission's
other post-employment benefit expense
and related liability by approximately
3.3 million
auditing standards require that we make
a number of disclosures to you which we
discussed earlier by KPMG in their
presentation and are included in our
other required Communications handout
included with your report
I will not discuss each item
individually but would like to note that
there was nothing that I need to bring
to your attention regarding required
disclosures
in accordance with the commission's
internal control over financial
reporting compliance and other matters
as a byproduct of our audit of the
financial statements
in our management letter that will be
presented to this committee at a future
meeting
I would like to thank the liquor
commission's management and staff as
well as Department administrative
services for their cooperation and
assistance throughout the audit
this concludes my part of the
presentation and with your commission
chairman Weiler I'd like to turn the
presentation over to Liquor Commission
chairman chairman Mullica
welcome
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee good afternoon for the record
I'm Joseph Malika chairman of the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission and with me
is Tina demirs our CFO we'd just like to
to thank Jim and his team for all the
hard work that they've done Steve and
Gene as well they come and we get an
audit every year so we're audited yearly
and we welcome those Audits and they are
always beneficial to us we're happy to
take any questions that you may have
thank you
you know it seems that people that get
audited every year are always happy and
and cooperative and the ones that every
fifth year or so say what's the matter
with you you know what are you
nitpicking me for you know maybe they
maybe we need to audit everybody every
year huh
calm down
any questions from the committee
representative leishman
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question so I noticed uh on
page 46 of the report uh
due to other state agencies
almost eight million dollars in the
previous year was like 623 thousand
dollars is there any reason why
something is not being given to the
other state agencies at this moment or
just not get the checks out yet that is
due to a timing of cash flow so at the
end of the year based on our payables
and what we have coming in for cash if
we have a negative cash at that time it
becomes a due to other state agencies
because we're pooled cash with Treasury
further questions further questions
thanks Mr chairman so I did notice my
town of Peterborough the sales were off
by a half a million dollars and the
largest Liquor Store in Nashua I think
was off more than 10 million dollars in
your overall revenues are off about 31
million dollars can you explain why
there's been such a decline in over the
last year of people going elsewhere or
no I don't think people are going
elsewhere represented I think we peaked
during the covet uh coat during the
covet incident people were staying at
home there certainly was a a lot more
purchasing going on at our stores and uh
that's that's declined some since then
I guess I don't have anything
further to that if you look at our sales
in comparison to pre-covered we still
have a significant growth over 2020.
back to the pre-year we're right on
target
thank you
people getting out and about the sales
would actually
and have increased but we'll see how it
goes thank you very much you're welcome
thank you well what we've noted in the
past is this agency is very quick at
opening a new place when the when the
previous one was showing a decline in
sales there a quick react to something
if if their sales are falling off
they'll open a store elsewhere
try to pick up that Revenue but they're
very quick I see in responding to the
market I'm impressed with it but I don't
know why what's going on in Peterborough
I I'm not responsible for any of this I
gave up drinking sorry about that
thank you for the compliment Mr chairman
we do our best thank you
anything further from the committee
congratulations you run a good operation
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee greatly appreciate it
thank you
anything further
uh
Michael Kane who have anything further
that we need to do uh just discuss the
date of the next meeting
the um it's up to the committee the
third Friday if you stay on the third
Friday that would be February 17th it's
up to you if that works for the
committee uh the following week is the
24th
Mr chair if we're anticipating absences
I I know I will not be here April 21st I
don't know if that's going to be a
fiscal day or not but
I'm out of the state
all right but you'll be here on the 17th
yes sir
all right uh
I'm talking April
oh
well we're not going that far ahead yet
February 17th
is that check
Senate's okay is that
chair is that going to be an after
another afternoon meeting it's going to
be what
another afternoon meeting
that one I'll put at 10 o'clock if that
works for everybody or do you prefer the
afternoon well I have a I have a
transportation council meeting but I can
probably get somebody to sit in for me
on that one what time is your
transportation 9 to 10 30.
all right would would you prefer an
afternoon
I'll get someone to sit in on New
Hampshire Transportation Council
10 o'clock is the preferred time
sorry
all right 10 o'clock
Friday February 17th will be our next
fiscal meeting
10 A.M
thank you all for your attendance and
thank you for my
alternate members for staying in the
loop
appreciate your your attention so when
these items come up again if they repeat
you'll know all about them
very good
it's unusual to have all the alternates
shall we show up but I don't mind it
all right
are we ready for the adjournment
move to adjourn in second any all in
favor say aye
we are adjourned thank you very much